hello and welcome to playstation grenade
marvel spider-man miles morales takes us
back into the web-slinging world but
this time
peter takes a back seat now that most of
us have finished the story
i think it's a good time to jump back in
and look at 30 secrets easter eggs and
nods to
marvel characters and lore it's actually
closer to 60 easter eggs but i took half
of these out as they were in the
original game back in 2018.
i'll link that video should you want to
find daredevil's locations and jessica
jones's top quality office
today it's just new stuff in 2020 and
mars adventure
let's do this
i think we should start with a doctor
who reference whilst playing the game
you'll be collecting caches and stashes
from the underground faction
when you find this hideout which
formerly belong to tombstone and his
gang
take a moment to check out the
mannequins on the way in
nothing out of place well completely
objective and miles will be in for a
surprise
did those mannequins move before miles
can get his head around events
the underground attack but rewinding for
a moment we see the mannequins move when
miles isn't looking
and to you doctor who fans you already
know the reference the weeping angels
these stone figures will hunt you down
and only eye contact
stops them approaching legit scared me
as a child
games like resident evil have used
mannequins moving to instill a little
tension
and it sure works sticking with the
theme of being scared
if you play the 2018 spider-man game you
are sure to remember these guys
complete nightmare fuel the people
inhabiting the boats around the island
were not made with pristine graphical
fidelity that's for sure
as they were never intended to be looked
at in such detail
but thanks to photo mode these guys
became known worldwide
when the remastered version of the game
released we all expected them to be
high-res
but no they are still frightening to
look at but there is one key difference
the model now has a post-it note applied
reading
did you miss us this shows that
insomniac embraced the meme culture and
added the easter egg instead of
upraizing the models
they have instead added a post-it note
wow i like it
by the way i'm using the remastered
edition to get this shot as it's
far easier for peter to get close enough
to these boats rather than miles
as the boats are very far away in the
winter time
speaking of insomniac remember when we
found their offices a few years ago
they are still here for miles to find
but insomniac found a way to hide their
logo in plain sight this time around
and i promise you've seen it during the
first mission to take down rhino
peter and miles find themselves carried
through buildings one of these is a maul
which is annihilated by rhino keep an
eye out and you'll see a chandelier used
as a halo over a christmas tree
this is actually insomniac's logo hidden
right in front of our eyes
so the scene where miles leaves his
apartment i decided to go back as
spider-man to see if anything happened
it didn't but then something else caught
our eye
the apartment numbers on the wall by
going into photo mode and checking these
out we can uncover
four more easter eggs one apartment is
for waldo
so if anyone asks where's waldo he's
here over in the uk we would call him
wally
and spend hours trying to find him
another apartment is for andy and buzz
which judging by the handwriting is a
toy story reference with andy writing
his name on his favorite toys
and one of those is buzz lightyear
another apartment has a cthulhu
reference and a sketch too
this is for you hp lovecraft fans and
the best one is just below
a blood soaked nameplate for fred and
jason
this has to be for the horror icons
freddy krueger and jason voorhees
from the friday the 13th series and look
f13 is there too
so four easy to miss easter eggs which
were in a cut
scene impressive how they hide these
things as we all know stan lee cameos in
marvel movies and video games have been
with us
for years in 2018 stan played mick
a restaurant owner which peter and mary
jane frequented
sadly stanley passed away before this
game was released
if you make your way to the upper side
district and use your spider sense a
statue will be revealed
get close enough and you'll see that
it's an in-game memorial to make the
restaurant owner
his statue has a touching quote to read
dedicated with love to the man who
nourished the hearts minds and souls of
true believers
everywhere excelsior and as we know
stan's trademark saying was
excelsior right in the fields you'll
never be forgotten mr lee
those of you who are trophy hunters
probably noticed the achievement pop-up
let's keep going with memorials and
trophies go north to the cemetery for
another one
get close enough and you'll spot miles's
dad's gravesite
jefferson davis interact there for a
moment it will make you think about your
own relationship with your father
i wish you were here dad here you can
also pay respects to uncle ben
and aunt may who sit side by side after
the events of the original game
and we can all learn something from aunt
may's grave when you help someone
you'll help everyone how about one more
crippling
sad thing once the game is complete
stick around until the very end of the
credits and you'll find a beautiful
memorial to black panther actor
chadwick boseman in loving memory of a
noble king chadwick boseman
his honor strength and compassion will
reverberate for generations to come
wakanda forever okay i can't take any
more sadness
let's move on to something absolutely
epic instead
so the into the spiderverse suit was
intended to be an easter egg but it was
so impressive
it was revealed two weeks before the
game released the added animation style
which sees miles moves on the second
frames was intended to be a secret for
movie lovers to find
that didn't pan out but there is also a
few other things hidden away to find
about miles and that spider-verse movie
i'm sure you've seen the acrobatics
miles can pull off on the streets
cool shizzle but not many people know
that it is possible to strike poses
directly from into the spider-verse and
other spider-man acrobatics from film
and comic book
miles is able to pull off the iconic
pose from the end of the spider-verse
movie
just remember to swing at the end of the
stunt or be prepared for another easter
egg
the exact fail animation from the movie
miles can also take out his phone
mid-air or simply strike
a laying pose and there's also my
personal favorite
the thinker which is a very real statue
found in france
posturing over the gates of hell and now
it's a spider-man pose
how times have changed here's a quick
tutorial to pull these off skip to this
time code if you're just here for more
easter eggs
the secret is actually learning to do
the inverted dive
holding down l3 as you reach the top of
a building and at the very last step
tapping r2 and x together once miles
will make this epic jump
just drag the laid back pose from the
movies hold square and hold the left
thumbstick upwards
for the other poses simply hold square
to strike the thinker dive
hold square and down on the left
thumbstick for miles to get his phone
out and hold square and push left or
right
to hit the draw me like your french
girl's pose
i struggled to master these and ended up
finding a great tutorial
online the chat is called oni zombies
i'll be sure to link the tutorial below
if you want to hit these poses
a few throw away easter eggs now should
miles jump off a building at a crazy
height and still be in control of his
body at the foot of the fall
he will not epically fail he'll strike a
superhero pose
deadpool will be proud the ground cracks
and shakes to understate how cool that
is
another returning easter egg from the
first game are the interactions miles
has on the streets
when not fighting the square button can
be pressed to do this
the finger point made famous by toby
maguire's peter parker
it's cringy but miles makes it look cool
again complete
with bioelectricity and don't be worried
miles won't be dancing like a white dad
on holiday
because he's got his own moves tap
square again near pedestrians and miles
well selsa i like that it's a good touch
oh whilst i was getting this footage i
took a look at the newspaper stand
in photo mode next to him and it's been
updated to reference miles as spider-man
it's not an easter egg but the attention
to detail is insane
another film reference back in 2018 was
a nod to toby maguire trying to stop a
train
it failed in the game but it was a good
reference this time around
there is a bridge scene set around tom
holland spider-man attempting to hold it
all together
like he did in the movie with a fairy
i'm sure you know that one already but i
thought i'd mention it to make sure we
get everything
okay more marvel easter eggs let's go
during the game you can find time
capsules miles and a friend hid years
ago
each references something from the comic
books here's a few of my favorites
the old library book is written by
ezekiel pendragon but look on the back
and you'll find a quote from ben urich
eric urich
i've never heard that name out loud from
ben urich in the marvel world he's an
investigative journalist
working for the daily bugle peter parker
sometimes works with him
but he usually appears in daredevil
stories his character was in the 2003
movie
and the 2015 tv show both versions
didn't do too well rip another
collectible looks like a pc graphics
card
but this one is all about the name on
the front handwritten
mastermind x4 this is a callback to
jason wingard
who was better known as mastermind the
extra detail
is really cool here x4 relates the first
comic book he appeared in
x-men number four next take a closer
look at the ticket stubs
a concert for dazzler and leila chaney
both
are marvel characters dazzler first
appeared in the uncanny x-men and has
the ability to convert
sound into energy and light dazzler
later appeared in the movie dark phoenix
leyla chaney on the other hand has a
teleportation ability
but she's also another musician making
this easter egg
perfectly suited next a direct reference
that takes little effort
the wheel miniature collectible this is
a nod to jackson wheel
also known as big wheel good name who
literally used a bright yellow ferris
wheel looking vehicle
thing and it's pure madness but to be
honest i'd probably watch a film about
that
and now the greatest accidental easter
egg in spider-man mars morales
it's possible to play as spooderman the
meme of spider-man
with the reduced jaw and the leaning
neck is here
but it isn't deliberate it seems to be a
glitch rather than an easter egg
but it's too good not to share to do
this you need to trick the game into
giving miles
peter's advanced suit to do this we
simply use the d-pad to choose a suit
then select it with x and circle at the
same time
now count to three and then click x
again
the suit will now be reset and miles
will wear peter's iconic suit
in some cutscenes this is truly epic it
feels like peter is
passing on the mantle to miles but in
other scenes
this can happen mr spark i don't feel
too good
like i said it's a glitch that's why the
model and the animations don't always
line up
leaving us with spooderman a meme from
80 years ago
finally has accidentally been recognized
this is totally gonna be patched out so
give it a go when you can
unleash your inner spooderman to end
well first a quick reminder if you want
to know what this dog is
taken from or where to find doctor
strange's sanctum santorum
i'll link that easter egg video at the
end of this video but to end now we are
going to look at the post-credit scene
just like in the previous game we can
take a solid guess at the next
spider-man outing here's what goes down
so it looks like in this version of
earth in which harry osborne is placed
in stasis by his father norman he has
finally awoken and judging by the black
web-like sludge
we should see a form of venom in peter
and miles's next adventure
damn that looks good but did you also
notice the scientist working on the
project
mr osborne i understand he's your son
but he's my woman
he's referred to as kurt which looks to
be kurt
connors who eventually becomes the
lizard
another one of spidey's enemies like a
crocodile thing wearing a lab coat
layman terms
so there we have it another 30 easter
eggs and secrets in spider-man miles
morales
let me know what i missed because i know
there's tons more to find
i'm adam from playstation grenade thank
you very much for your time i'm going
back to player spider-man
where the hell is my head
[Music]